Your AI agent doesn't remember a single
thing you tell it. Every message you
send, it [music] wakes up with total
amnesia and some piece of software you
probably didn't think much about
scrambles to fake a memory before the
model can answer. The fake is what
everyone calls agent memory and right
now it's the messiest, most argued over
corner of building with AI. A whole
industry is selling you ways to make
your agent remember more. Though the
thing that separates working memory from
memory that wrecks your agent is knowing
what to throw away. By the end of this
video, you'll know why the model forgets
at all, what agent memory is, the one
reason more memory can make your agent
worse, and the boring setup that's all
most agents will [music] ever need. We
should start with the simple part. Why
does your agent forget? The model itself
is stateless. One request goes in, one
answer comes out. And the instant it
finishes, the model throws everything
away. It doesn't know you, it doesn't
know the last thing it said. Every turn
it's meeting you for the first time. So
how does a chat feel continuous at all?
Your tool cheats. Before each turn, it
pastes the whole conversation back in
>> [music]
>> behind the scenes. So the model can read
what already happened and act like it
remembered. That repasting is the only
reason anything sticks and statelessness
isn't some bug they forgot to fix. It's
[music] the thing that lets one model
serve millions of people at once without
everyone's conversations bleeding into
each other. Memory gets stretched over
three different things. The context
window is the model's workspace for a
single answer, the text it can see right
now. Think of it as RAM, fast, small,
wiped the moment the job's done.
Retrieval, what most people call RAG, is
[music] a read. You keep a pile of
documents, and when a question comes in,
you go fetch the chunks that look
relevant and drop them in. A library you
can search. Memory is the part that
writes. It watches what happens, [music]
decides something is worth keeping, and
saves it so a future session can use it.
That last one is where the real work
lives. Rag reads from a shelf someone
already stocked. [music] Memory decides
what goes on the shelf and what gets
pulled back off when it turns out to be
wrong.
If memory is the writing, something has
to do the writing. This is where the
"It's a database in a costume" complaint
comes from, and it's worth being precise
about. A good memory system isn't a
place you dump text. It's a loop wrapped
around the model with two halves. The
write path is the remembering. After a
turn, a separate process reads back over
what just happened and asks one hard
question: Is anything here worth
keeping? Mostly, no. The model's own
filler, half its reasoning, the 15 tool
calls that went nowhere, all noise. The
good systems bin that and keep the few
durable facts. You switch from Python to
TypeScript. The deploy failed on an auth
step. This user hates early flights.
Then it reconciles them against what it
already knew. So a new fact overrides
the old one instead of piling up beside
[music] it. The read path is the
recalling. A new turn comes in, and
before the model sees anything, the loop
decides what's relevant, pulls a handful
of the right memories, ranks them, and
pastes only those into the window. Not
the whole pile, only the best few.
Write, store, reconcile, retrieve, rank,
forget. That's the loop. And notice
what's doing the work, not the database
underneath. Swap the vector store for a
graph or for a plain text file, and the
loop is the same. What makes memory
sharp or useless is the controller
making those keep or toss calls. That is
something that can't be sold in a box.
You would think the fix is obvious.
Models take a million tokens of context
now, so stop deleting things. Paste the
entire history in every time and let the
model sort it out. More memory, fewer
problems. It runs the [music] other way.
A model with a giant window doesn't read
across all of it evenly. Researchers at
Chroma pushed 18 of the top models
through longer and longer inputs, and
every single one got less reliable as
the input grew. Even on easy lookups.
They named it context rot. The window
fills, the signal drowns, and the model
starts skimming. You've likely felt this
as well. Early in a session, an agent
follows your instructions almost every
time. Bury those same instructions under
a few thousand tokens of chat history,
and its compliance falls through the
floor, down to roughly [music] a third
by the time a conversation's run long.
So, the job flips. A memory [music]
system proves its worth by how much it
throws away. Keep the active context
small, sharp, and mostly empty, and the
model stays clear-headed, which makes
the controller's hardest and most
valuable job forgetting on purpose.
Don't think there's a solution for it,
by the way. Forgetting on purpose sounds
clean until you try to write the rule
for it, knowing what to keep. There's no
reliable signal for this is important.
Keep too much, and you're back to
context rot. Keep too little, and you
bin the one detail that turns out to
matter three days later. The model can't
tell, and neither can a simple
heuristic. Then stillness. Yesterday you
preferred Python, today it's TypeScript.
A naive system stores both, retrieves
both, and now the agent holds two facts
that contradict each other with no idea
which one is true now. Getting the new
fact to override the old one instead of
sitting next to it is one of the open
problems. There's retrieval precision.
Search finds what's similar, not what's
correct. Ask about your current task and
it'll happily surface a three-day-old
log that happens [music] to use the same
words. Similar is not the same as right.
And the silent one. You often [music]
can't tell if any of it is working.
Memory failures don't throw errors. The
agent just gets a little worse and you
won't notice it until it confidently
forgets something it shouldn't have.
There are benchmarks for this like long
mem eval and they show even strong
setups dropping around 30% of their
accuracy over a long multi-session
chats. The trouble is every vendor posts
a great score on their own benchmark and
those scores rarely survive someone else
running the test. So treat the numbers
as marketing.
One more thing because it changes how
you should think about the whole system.
The moment your agent writes things down
and trusts them later, that memory
becomes a target. A normal [music]
prompt injection is a one-shot problem.
Someone slips a bad instruction in, the
agent does something dumb for one turn,
the session ends, it's gone. But say
your agent reads a poisoned line of a
shared read me or an email, decides it's
a useful fact and writes it to long-term
memory. That attack doesn't end with the
session, it waits. Days later in a
completely different and maybe
privileged session, the agent pulls that
memory back up and runs it with no clue
it was planted. Researchers have landed
these implants more than 90% [music] of
the time using nothing but ordinary
looking messages. Persistent memory
turns a passing exploit into a sleeper
agent.
So, what does all this mean for you
building something this week? Almost
certainly less than the market wants to
sell you. Most working developers don't
run a memory system at all. They write
things down. A Claude MD or Agents MD
file with the project standing facts. A
notes file the agent appends [music] to.
Git history which is already a clean
record of what got done and why. When a
conversation gets long, summarize the
old turns and drop the raw transcript.
[music]
Add one small table of durable facts per
user looked up exactly and not by
similarity [music]
and you've killed the number one
complaint. It forgot my preference with
no vector database in sight. The heavy
tools, Mem Zero, Let A Zap, all of them
are worth it the day you can prove you
need them. Real [music] cross-session
personalization,
a code base too big to summarize, a
swarm of agents that have to share
state. Until you hit one of those walls,
a fancy memory layer mostly buys you
more tokens, more latency, and more ways
to fail. Whatever you do, write the test
first. Five questions on your own data.
One about a stable preference. One about
a fact that changed. One the agent
should refuse to answer because nobody
ever told it. If you can't measure
whether memory helped, you can't tell a
system that works from one that only
feels [music] like it does.
Zoom out and the field is settling on
one shape even while it argues about
everything else. Nobody has won the
database. Vector, graph, files, they all
still have their believers. What people
are converging on is the loop. Write,
store, reconcile, retrieve, rank,
[music] forget. All of it running under
a tight budget of what the model can
actually hold. When your agent forgets
something it shouldn't, the problem is
almost never the storage. It's [music]
the decision about what deserved to be
stored and what should have been thrown
out. The controller, not the database
underneath it. Get that decision right
and a markdown file goes a long way. Get
it [music] wrong and the most expensive
memory stack on the market just helps
your agent forget faster. For most
agents you'll ever build, memory is a
markdown file and a habit. Reach for
more the day you can prove you need it
and not a day before.